tu commencé à l'âge de 5 ans par la
danse les percus et à l'âge de 9 ans
j'ai monté mon premier groupe
je voudrais batterie à 13 ans le
deuxième groupe express jouer de la
guitare basse et et cetera et cetera
jusqu'à ce que je parte en france pour
étudier le trombone sérieusement 59 ans
et en martinique
c'est en martinique juste que je suis
resté appartenait jusqu'à l'âge de 19
ans à basse pointe et après je suis
parti vers les études
de musique en france et bien d'autres
qu'est ce que ça fait ça le nourrit ça
nourrit de la musique de l'expérience
des autres du véhicule des autres et la
musique c'est quelque chose qui se
partagent donc moi je peux soudas la
rencontre des musiques musiciens du
monde entier
donc quand j'étais gamin je me rappelle
je rêvais de l'hexagone de tous ces
groupes et finalement j'ai joué avec eux
donc
et ça c'est grâce au travail c'est le
travail qui permet d'avancer de
rencontrer des gens parce que ce qui en
est toujours au même niveau on avance
passer ces médias les gens font pas
appel à nous donc que moche toujours dit
que si on joue bien on sera toujours
appelé pour jouer alors le rêve accompli
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui reste
quelle motivation la motivation c'est
toute la musique que j'ai écrite
plus de 200 morceaux la réaliser l'âme
est l écoute du monde entier voilà et ça
c'est le plus gros ce qui reste à faire
et c'est ce que tu fais ce que je fais
en ce moment avec mon nouvel album neg
marrons des ou parce que j'ai tenu à
présenter navarre tennis était d'abord
et ensuite
là je pars vous présentez socialement ne
reste du monde voilà en commençant par
l'europe l'europe l'abbé le récit sera
au moins deux nouveaux plats sinon il ya
la pologne aussi à lisa simon pères
pardon liz mc comb
au mois d'octobre je continue à
travailler aussi avec d'autres artistes
parce que c'est important d'échanger
surtout avec les lycées ici c'est la
diva quoi elle m'a énormément à mener si
je peux faire une comparaison moi je la
compare à quelqu'un comme miles davis
voilà quelqu'un comme miles davis qui
s'est passé et qui s'est trouvé les
musiciens et puis une liste m'a raconté
ses expériences à la nouvelle-orléans h
et 6 6 heures d'affilée ça il faut le
faire c'est là ya du métier il ya du
poids donc voilà ces gens là je tiens
encore à les côtoyer apprendre à côté
d'eux parce que la route est longue ce
n'est pas fini
voilà même si j'ai un certain niveau
mais encore qu'ils sont plus forts que
moi et encore devant à faire et j'espère
que c'est pas fini pour graisser quoi